foreign
Odessa Texas hi Angela welcome to the
Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
so I just have a quick question we are
26 the only debt we have is our home
mortgage which sits at 169 thousand and
we currently have about a little over 11
000 into cryptocurrency and our question
was what would be the next step would we
leave it there or would we take it out
and invest that money somewhere else
well if I'm you I am not going to stay
invested in crypto the track record has
been poo poo uh over the Long Haul so I
would take that money out almost
instantly are you guys investing in
401ks or IRAs anything for retirement
um
it's the only one working and he does
have a
we have a 401k in the Roth I believe
it's called
do you guys have any money set aside for
savings that's kind of liquid that you
can get to
yes we do how much
um I want to say we have about 13 000
right now okay so you got a good solid
emergency fund and then it's time to do
some real investing crypto is
um gambling
right and I think you know I'm gonna I
don't want to do you know that the that
the you know the last year and a half
have been really unkind to crypto
yes I remember watching it during covid
but right after we invested and I
remember watching it go really low and
then going back up high and now we're
just sitting there
but I mean you've noticed the news that
one of the largest scams in history was
perpetrated in crypto
yes yes sir makes makes Bernie Madoff
look like small potatoes okay so the the
scams are all everywhere around it the
it's an ins it's an unstable place to
put money agreed
yes sir okay all right so I don't put
places I don't put money in places that
are unstable
someday crypto May stabilize and someday
it may have a track record but until it
does I won't be putting any money in it
and I was saying that back when I had
got entire pages of Reddit devoted to
hating me and entire pages of uh Tic Tac
hating me
um and everything because I'm telling
people not to put money in stupid but
crypto Come On Dave so um but you know
and now I'm now I'm a genius you know
but I also told them not to invest their
money in Beanie Babies a few years ago
and people were believing in that too so
it's almost like you've lived to see a
few things it's almost like years it's
almost like yeah that's how I lost my
hair yeah